(helicopter rotors rumbling)
- [Shelby] After striking
a new military base
deal in the Philippines,
the US is making moves
to counter China's growing
militarization of the Pacific.
- China's military buildup is astonishing.
To some, it's impressive.
- And it's not showing
any signs of slowing down.
- It's not showing any
signs of slowing down.
- [Shelby] These troops trained
for a potential conflict
on islands just a hundred
miles from Taiwan,
the self-ruled island that China
has threatened to take
by force if necessary.
(munitions whooshing)
And powerful American weapons
were tested over the South China Sea,
where China's militarized islands
are threatening its neighbors.
- What the US is doing now,
we wish it did decades back.
- [Shelby] But after more than 20 years
of Chinese expansion,
can the US and its allies
successfully change the balance
of power in the Pacific?
(artillery firing)
The Philippines, a US treaty ally,
lies southeast of mainland China.
To its west is the South China Sea,
a global shipping route
full of natural resources.
And to the north is Taiwan,
a key US trading partner.
Beijing says both Taiwan
and much of the sea
are part of China, and has
ramped up its military presence
to bolster those claims.
- [Reporter] How concerned are you
with the continued provocation from China?
- As concerned as you could possibly be.
It is one of the major
issues that we have to face.
- [Shelby] The Philippines' new president,
Ferdinand Bongbong Marcos
Jr., has leaned into the US
after years of a more pro-China policy
under his predecessor, Rodrigo Duterte.
This year, Washington and
Manila struck a major base deal
that increased the number of sites
the US can use in the
Philippines from five to nine
under the Enhanced Defense
Cooperation Agreement.
The new sites bring the US military closer
to both Taiwan and the South China Sea.
And the deal allows the
US to build facilities,
position equipment, and rotate
troops through the bases.
(Tan speaking in foreign language)
- The new sites have angered China,
which has accused the US
of intentionally stoking
regional tensions.
One of the phrases that I've heard
is the US could use these bases
as staging grounds against China.
Is that what they are?
- I think you could
feasibly see that they are,
but we wouldn't do any of that
without the consent of
the Philippine Government.
China is a free and sovereign nation.
And as long as they act
within the international-based,
rules-based order here in the region,
they have plenty of room to operate.
- [Shelby] Major General
Joseph Ryan commands
the Army's 25th Infantry Division.
We met him on the USS Miguel
Keith in the Luzon Strait.
The Luzon Strait is a strategic waterway
that's a major commercial shipping lane
and a key transit point
for both the Chinese and US militaries.
In the event of a conflict over Taiwan,
control of the strait would be critical.
(soldier speaking in foreign language)
- [Shelby] Chinese exercises
in and around the strait
have heightened concerns
about a war in the region.
And because the US and the Philippines
have a mutual defense treaty,
the US would be obligated
to defend the country if it's attacked.
- Geography matters.
There's certainly a sense
that should a conflict occur
in Taiwan, that the
Philippines would be affected.
- Is the US prepared to fight?
- Absolutely.
And that's what we're doing here.
(upbeat music)
- We followed Major General
Ryan and his joint unit
onto Marine Ospreys and traveled
to some of the northernmost
islands in the Philippines.
(helicopter rotors whirring)
The objective of the drill,
to secure the area and then expand it,
making room for even bigger
firepower like this HIMARS,
an offensive weapon system that's capable
of reaching the southern part
of Taiwan from this island.
- A HIMARS rocket system
on the island here
could certainly influence
not only the land space
but the maritime space
beyond just where it sits
here on Basco Island.
- [Shelby] Along the coast
of the South China Sea,
the US and Philippine
militaries conducted live fires
of the HIMARS and other
advanced American weapons,
like Stingers and Patriots,
marking a major escalation of
the exercises from years past.
(soldiers cheering)
For years, Beijing has used
this so-called nine-dash line
to roughly outline what
it says belongs to China.
The dashes are believed
to be based on maps
used by the Republic of China in 1947.
Within those lines, these satellite images
show how China has turned
reefs into artificial islands
and added airstrips, missile silos,
and communication towers.
- That offends Filipinos.
It's like you always have a
dagger pointed towards you.
- [Shelby] General Emmanuel Bautista
became the chief of staff of
the Philippine Armed Forces
in 2013, the year the
Philippines took China to court
over its contested claims.
The Philippines won the landmark case,
but China has refused
to recognize the ruling.
To maintain control, its
ships have repeatedly harassed
its neighbors' coast guard vessels
and civilian fishing boats,
blocking their passage with larger ships,
military grade lasers,
and even water cannons.
- China is violating our
sovereignty and sovereign rights.
And regardless if there is a competition,
we have an issue with
China in that respect.
- [Shelby] Polls show most Filipinos
support stronger ties with the US
to help the country
defend its sovereignty.
And despite China's warnings
not to interfere in the South China Sea,
the country is in talks with the US
and other Pacific allies like Japan
to launch joint patrols later this year.
- Our goal is peace,
security, stability, and
creating opportunity.
It's not to engage in a new Cold War,
it's not to contain China.
- [Shelby] Some experts
say it might be too late
to change the balance
of power in the region.
China now has more naval
ships, more ICBM launchers,
more active service members,
and potentially more
sophisticated missile capabilities
than the US.
But the US is counting on
its alliances in the Pacific
to push back.
And in recent months, Washington
has increased security ties
with Japan, Australia, and South Korea.
And it has pledged to expedite
weapon sales to Taiwan.
- The asymmetric
advantage of our alliances
and partnerships in the region
is part of what separates us from the PRC,
because they don't have that.
- The relationships.
- They don't have the relationships.
Combat-credible forces,
allied and together,
win wars.
So if conflict happens,
I'm confident we're prepared to fight it.
(helicopter rotors whirring)
(lighthearted music)